Did you know that the demon king
Muzan was married five times? Or
that Tanjiro is one of only three
people confirmed to have seen the
legendary Blue Spider Lily? Or that two
of the Hashira secretly loved each other?
And ironically one half of that secret
relationship is the Love Hashira, Mitsuri
Kanroji. But what’s maybe even more incredible is
that she is actually the only Hashira who didn’t
have some sort of horribly traumatic childhood.
That’s because she grew up in a normal family
with five kids where her biggest problem was that
her ridiculous physical strength kept scaring away
potential husbands. And besides her strength, her
pink hair was also a real issue with the guys. But
I think it’s kinda cool because she is actually
the only anime girl I know of that has a reason
for her wacky hair color. That’s because hers
only turned this bright pink because she ate way,
way too much sakura mochi. All this led to
Mitsuri being pretty depressed, however,
she decided she didn’t want to fake who
she was to find a husband so she joined
the demon slayer corps after the leader told
her that she should embrace her true abilities.
Which is when the real drama starts
because she secretly fell in love
with one of the other Hashira,
who we’ll talk about later on.
Continuing with the anime characters, the
Upper Moon Six demons Daki and Gyutaro were
not nearly as fortunate growing up as Mitsuri.
These two were born to a prostitute mother,
and she was such a terrible mom that she
actually tried to kill both of them. Their
mom particularly was jealous of Daki and
even tried to cut off her beautiful hair,
but Gyutaro went on a rampage to save his sister.
However, Gyutaro was not as fortunate in the looks
department, and he was constantly mocked for his
appearance, voice, and his poor hygiene. Which
I mean come on, who wouldn’t have bad teeth if
they were forced to eat bugs and rats to survive.
Gyutaro couldn’t always protect Daki
though because years later when she
was a successfulOiran, she stabbed a samurai
for mocking her brother. This made the samurai
furious, and he tied her up and literally
burned her alive. Gyutaro barely managed to
save her and he killed the samurai as revenge.
And if that wasn’t bad enough no one would even
help the siblings until the Upper Rank demon
Doma found them and turned them into demons.
And that’s how the pair came to terrorize
the Entertainment district for centuries.
However there is another super powerful, early
story character who I bet you didn’t know was
mocked for his looks. This is Sakonji
Urokodaki, the former Water Hashira who
first trained Tanjiro and the current Water
Hashira, Giyu. Among his many other feats,
Urokodaki is famous for capturing and
imprisoning the Hand Demon that was the
main enemy during Tanjiro’s test to become a
demon slayer. But despite being crazy strong,
he apparently has a soft side because demons
used to make fun of his gentle features,
and this bothered him SO much that he started
wearing these fox masks to hide his face.
And of course you might recognize these masks
because they were also worn by these spirits,
Makomo and Sabito. These two were orphans
who were trained by Urokodaki. Makomo
lived sometime before Sabito, and when
she went for her Final Selection test,
she was killed by the hand demon. The same is
true for Sabito, who was also killed by this
ugly monstrosity. Though apparently Sabito
took the test at the same time as Giyu and he
actually saved Giyu during their week on the
mountain. But because of their failures both
of these two became spirits who lived on the
mountain where they helped Tanjiro to train.
Plus as I already mentioned, their killer
was this disgusting figure who was captured
and imprisoned by Urokodaki, but we
also know that the very first person
this demon killed was his older brother
after he was first turned into a demon.
That’s nowhere near as insane as the Drum demon’s
backstory though because this demon used to be
a member of the Twelve Kizuki, which are the
twelve strongest demons in the world. However,
he somehow lost his ability to
grow stronger from eating humans,
so the demon king Muzan took away his
position. Ever since then the drum demon
has been obsessed with growing
stronger to regain his position.
Another character who lost something important
is this guy – actually wait, pretty much every
character in this story has lost someone important
to them. Anyway, this is Shinjuro Rengoku, who is
the father of the Flame Hashira from the
Mugen Train arc. He was married to Ruka,
and also had another son named Shenjuro.
Shinjuro used to be the former flame hashira,
and even saved this guy from his super tragic
past which we’ll discuss more later on.
But Shinjuro became a deadbeat
dad after his wife died. In fact,
he was so torn up about his wife’s death that
when he encountered a lower rank demon, he took
out his anger by cutting it up over and over
again, but never actually killing the monster.
Now even though demons are mostly all awful
monsters, that doesn’t mean that they can’t
have some serious trauma of their own. This is
perfectly shown by the Lower Moon Five demon,
Rui, who was actually born to a normal
family with parents who loved him. He
was a pretty weak child though, so when
Muzan offered to make him a strong demon,
he immediately accepted the offer. But after
killing a household servant, Rui’s parent’s
tried to kill him because they didn’t want him
to become a monster. Whoops, too late for that.
So Rui actually killed his beloved parents and
then spent the next twenty years unsuccessfully
trying to recreate that special family vibe with
demons that he transformed into fellow spiders.
And if you think that is twisted, then just
wait until you hear about Enmu’s disturbing
past. When he was a human he could actually not
tell the difference from dreams or reality. Which
sounds interesting, but as an adult this
led him to pretend to be a doctor and he
would tell patients that they were healed
even though they were about to die. What a
crazy messed up thing to do. But that’s
not even the worst part because one day
the demon king was literally in the middle of
eating Enmu, but instead of being terrified
he actually praised Muzan which somehow
convinced him to turn Enmu into a demon.
Wow, I never actually realized how messed up
backstories in demon slayer are until making
this video. In fact the standard backstory for
a character is basically just “family killed
by demons”, which is true for these three
little helpers from the Butterfly Mansion,
whose names are Sumi, Kiyo, and Naho.
And the same can be said for Aoi,
however she has a bit more to her backstory
because at one point she was actually able to
pass the test to become a demon slayer,
although she claims it was pure luck.
And each of these characters were taken
in by the Flower Hashira, Shinobu Kocho,
whose parents were – you guessed it – also killed
by demons. But she and her sister were actually
saved by the Stone Hashira, who has literally
one of the most heroic backstories in the manga
which we’ll discuss later on. But one other fact
about Shinobi that you may not know is that her
uniform was actually supposed to be incredibly
revealing - just like Mitsuri’s - however,
she immediately burned the open-chested
jacket and requested a fully buttoned one.
Another mind-blowing fact about Shinobu’s past
is that she became the head of the butterfly
mansion at just 14 years old! That’s wild, I
mean kids in this world basically seem like
adults once they hit 10. But Shinobu only
got this role because her older sister,
Kanae, died in a battle against the Upper
Rank demon, Doma. But before she died,
Kanae and Shinobu both rescued this
young girl from her terrible childhood.
But it turns out being a slave wasn’t even
the worst part of Kanao Tsuyuri’s backstory.
That’s because she grew up with parents
who were so abusive that she literally
had a mental breakdown and repressed all of her
emotions. Her parents then sold her into slavery,
where she was rescued by the Kocho sisters.
They took her to the butterfly mansion and
she eventually learned Flower breathing from
just watching Shinobu and Kanea. This made
her so strong that she took the Final Selection
test without her adoptive sisters’ permission.
And while Kanao’s traumatic
past might break your heart,
no one should cry over this sickening liar right
here. This is the Upper Rank 4 demon Hantengu,
who was such a frequent liar during his human
life that he would commit horrible crimes and
then cry and scream that he was innocent.
His mind was even so twisted that he was
married multiple times but would always
end up killing his own family. However,
he was eventually caught and sentenced to
death, only to be turned into a demon by Muzan.
While all of that is pretty messed up, his partner
in the attack on the swordsmith village is even
more disturbing. That’s because as a child,
Gyokko’s parents drowned while out fishing at
sea. Eventually he saw their bodies washed up on
shore and developed a sickening fascination with
corpses and in particular dead fish. This led his
village to believe he had gone insane. Eventually,
Gyokko killed another kid who was making fun
of him. However, the murdered kid’s parents
got their revenge by stabbing Gyokko. But
unfortunately for the rest of the world,
he somehow managed to survive until
he was turned into a demon by Muzan.
Which of course meant that he could continue
making his creepy body art until he was defeated
by the Mist Hashira, Muicihiro Tokito.
But like pretty much all the Hashira,
his childhood was awfully tragic. Muichiro and his
twin brother were born into a woodcutting family,
but his mom died from illness and his father
fell off a cliff. Wow, there’s a new way to
die in the story. Their parents’ deaths left
the twins to survive on their own. However,
the leader of the demon slayers actually tried
to recruit the boys many times, but Muichiro’s
brother always turned them down. So they continued
their life until a demon came and attacked them,
leaving Muichiro’s brother dead. Muichiro managed
to kill the demon, but seeing his brother die
literally broke his mind and he lost all of his
memories and personality. Luckily he was found
by the demon slayers, and after recovering
he became a Hashira in the insanely short
time of two months. Which may sound crazy
but it actually makes sense considering he
has a super strong relative from the past who
we will talk about at the end of the video.
But Muichiro is not the only descendant of a
crazy strong bloodline. That’s because this
flashy Hashira came from a legendary clan of
Shinobi. But as cool as that sounds, Tengen’s
childhood was pretty awful. By the age of 15 he
is basically forced into getting married, which
I guess isn’t all bad when these three are your
wives, but the worst part is that he and his eight
siblings were forced to face each other in death
matches until only the two strongest survived.
However, when Tengen learned he was
actually killing his brothers and sisters,
he left the clan and never returned. And while he
sometimes thought about wiping out his terrible
clan altogether, he could never bring himself
to kill his dad and only remaining brother.
Which is honorable in its own way, but it’s
not the only broken brotherly bond in the
story. Because Genya and his brother Sanemi
have actually never gotten along after their
tragic childhood. Their abusive father was
randomly stabbed by someone in the village
and their mom worked tirelessly to provide for
the family. That is until she was turned into a
demon and attacked her own family. All the kids
were killed except Genya and his older brother,
who somehow managed to kill their demon
mom. However, young Genya panicked and
shouted at Sanemi for killing their mom,
and the two have never gotten along since.
Later both boys joined the demon
corps where Genya learned he cannot
use breathing techniques, but he does
actually have the super rare ability to
consume demon flesh and gain some
demonic strength and healing.
And Genya’s heroics during the swordsmith village
arc helped save everyone’s favorite swordsmith,
Haganezuka. Apparently, his massive temper
tantrums have been an issue ever since he
was a kid, and he even caused his
parents to have mental breakdowns,
which resulted in Haganezuka
being raised by the village chief.
Which based on all of the orphans there seem
to be in this story, it is a good thing there
are so many old men willing to take these kids
in. Because even Zenitsu was not raised by his
parents. In fact, when he was on his own as a
kid he gave all his money to some random crush,
who then stole it and ran away with another
dude. Ah, poor guy. Lost it all for love. But
This left Zenitsu in terrible debt until this
old man, Jigoro, took him in and trained him
as a swordsman. However, Zenitsu was so scared
of training that one day he climbed a tree and
was then struck by lightning. Which permanently
changed his hair to its now familiar yellow.
And while this made the Jigoro furious,
he still cared for Zenitsu like a son.
And this is a pretty cool trainer to
have, since he was a former Thunder
Hashira who only retired when he lost his
leg during a battle when he was thirty-five.
One character who isn’t as cool is
the Temari demon from season one,
Susamaru, who apparently loved to play
with these hand balls even as a human.
Then we have Murata, who was one of the only
survivors of the spider demon attack on Mount
Natagumo. Though apparently before becoming
a demon slayer a girl he liked complimented
his hair, which is why he regularly grooms and
applies camellia oil to keep its silky look.
Nice to see that someone in this dangerous
world actually takes care of themselves.
Next up is the man who saved Tanjiro, Zenitsu,
and Inosuke after the entertainment district
arc. This is Goto, a member of the clean up
brigade, but did you know that he actually
was worthy of becoming a demon slayer.
However, he chose to be one of the helpers
instead? Hmm, I wonder why that was? Just like
I’m also wondering why you are not subscribed
to the channel right now. So go ahead and click
that button for even more amazing anime content.
But now for one of the characters you would never
expect to play an important role. This is Yushiro,
who was once a sick boy under the care of the
gentle demon Tamayo. With Yushiro about to die,
Tamayo asked if he wanted to become a kind
demon just like herself so that he could
live. He agreed, and has been at her side ever
since. However, he actually loves Tamayo deeply,
which may sound childish, but their bond actually
plays a huge role in the end of the story.
Now at this point you might be wondering where
our main character is, but don’t worry because
we will be getting to him very soon. But first,
did you know that Tanjiro’s mother, Kie Kamado,
actually knows where to find the legendary
Blue Spider Lily flowers? We learned in the
special fanbook number two that she knew
where to find the special flower and we
even see that Tanjiro had a flashback to the
flower during his fight with Rui. But that’s
not all we know about Kie because apparently
she once killed a boar with her incredibly
hard head. So it seems like we finally know
where Tanjiro got THAT special skill from.
Of course that’s not the only
special skill in the family,
because Tanjiro’s father, Tanjuro, was
able to use the legendary Sun Breathing,
which of course has been passed down through their
family line. Tanjuro was also incredibly strong,
though he had no connection with the demon
slayer crops. However, there was an even
more legendary ability that we learn later on
in the story, which he passed down to his son.
But first we have Tanjiro’s siblings,
Takeo, Hanako, Shigeru, and Rokuto,
who were all killed by Muzan. Of
course we can’t leave out Nezuko,
who helped the family by going without new
clothes and other items to make sure that
the family had food. She was most often
helping her mother around their home.
Which brings us to Tanjiro. And we’ve just
discussed his family and their humble upbringing,
but there were a few other exciting events
throughout the early parts of his life. Like
when he got his famous scar after saving his
brother from a hot kettle. He also learned the
basics of Sun Breathing by watching his father
perform their traditional rituals. But there
is one scene from later on in the manga that
also showed us that his father could use the
overpowered ability Transparent World. This super
rare ability lets you see through someone’s skin
down to their muscles and bones. We know this
because in chapter 151 his sickly father easily
killed a massive bear. His father then told
him that with enough practice his mind would
not need to think but he would just be able
react to what he was seeing. Unfortunately,
his father died from his illness a few days later,
and Tanjiro then inherited the hanafuda earrings.
And as sad as it is to see Tanjiro lose his
father, at least he had a solid family for
most of his life. The same can’t be said for
Inosuke. At least, not a human family. Of course
he did have parents, but his mother fled with
baby Inosuke because his father was horribly
abusive. They eventually came to the twisted
cult who worshiped the Upper Moon two demon Doma,
but when his mother realized that Doma was eating
people, she ran away once again. Unfortunately,
Doma chased her and she was forced to throw baby
Inosuke into a river before Doma caught up and ate
her. Eventually, Inosuke was found by boars, which
is how he grew up until he became a demon slayer.
Which actually turned out pretty well for him,
but it all started with another deadbeat husband,
and I’m starting to think that they are just
as evil as the demons in this story. Another
example of this is from the biwa demon’s backstory
from later on in the manga. That’s because when
she was a human she was a decent biwa player
who struggled to make much money. However,
her husband would gamble away even what
little money they had. And when he sold
her only nice kimono she got so furious
that she straight up killed him. But that
very same night when she went on stage
to perform, her musical performance was
so amazing that she actually continued
to commit murder every time she had a
performance. This continued until she tried to
kill Muzan, but he then turned her into a demon.
So again, who is the real evil
here, demons or awful husbands?
Which just goes to show that good dads are
super rare, just like Tanjiro’s great ancestor,
Sumiyoshi Kamado. This man lived with his wife
Suyako and their daughter Sumire about 500
years before the current story. This family
was actually attacked by demons and luckily
saved by the legendary swordsman Yoriichi,
who we’ll discuss in full detail in just a
moment. But this was a super important moment
for the story because Sumiyoshi became friends
with Yoriichi and eventually the troubled
swordsman told Tanjiro’s ancestor his life
story. AND THE MOST IMPORTANT PART was that
Yoriichi showing Sumiyoshi Sun Breathing,
which is how it got passed down the
family line all the way to Tanjiro.
But of course the original Sun Breather has
also one of THE MOST intense and complicated
backstories in the entire story. This is Yoriichi
Tsugikuni who lived around 500 years ago. He is
literally the strongest demon slayer ever and was
the one who first created the breathing styles of
fighting. Yoriichi grew up with his twin brother
Michikatsu, and when they were growing up he was
a very quiet, kind child who took care of
his sick mother. However he literally did
not speak at all as a kid, so his father was
going to send him to a temple. This is actually
how he first got the hanafuda earrings because
his mother gave them to him because she hoped
that they would help him to finally speak.
But everyone lost their minds when they saw
him do this during sword practice. While his
brother struggled to even touch the instructor,
Yoriichi pciked up the practice sword for the
first time. He then instantly struck the teacher
four times and left him with massive bumps and
bruises. Which left everyone mind blow, but the
excitement was short lived because Yoriichi didn’t
like the feeling of hitting someone, so he did not
pick up a weapon again while he lived at home.
But his legendary strength meant that his father
instantly started to show him more affection.
He even decided to send his twin brother to the
temple instead of Yoriichi. This of course made
his brother incredibly jealous, but Yoriichi’s
super insane strength was not the only thing
that separated the two. Yoriichi was actually
born with the demon slayer mark, which basically
makes a person much stronger, and he could even
naturally see the Transparent World, which was how
he knew his mother was sick when no one else did.
But when their mother finally died of her illness,
Yoriichi decided to leave home so that his brother
would not be sent to the temple. After leaving, he
met his wife Uta, and years later they were about
to have a baby. But just like any happy thing in
these backstories, a demon came and messed it up.
While Yoriichi was going to get a midwife to help
his wife give birth, Uta was attacked and killed.
This drove Yoriichi to intense sadness, and he
even held his wife’s body for ten days straight.
After this time of grieving he became a demon
slayer. Which was a completely game-changing
moment. Because of his natural talent, he taught
the other slayers everything that he knew,
which included adapting Sun Breathing into new
breathing styles to suit each individual person.
Years later, Yoriichi encountered Muzan and
Tamayo, and while the demon king was a genuine
threat, the legendary demon slayer instantly
defeated him and the demon only barely managed
to escape. Then Yoriichi let Tamayo go free,
but next we have the dumbest moment in the
entire story. That’s because soon after this event
several other Demon slayers confronted Yoriichi
amd kicked him out of the demon slayers
because his brother had become a demon,
which we’ll discuss more in just a
moment. Which is absolutely crazy,
but is the reason he eventually went to
talk with Sumiyoshi Kamado about his life.
Skipping ahead sixty years, Yoriichi
encountered with his demon brother
one last time, but actually died
of old age during this battle.
Which literally drove his brother mad with
rage. I mean how would you feel if you spent
your whole life trying to beat your brother,
but then when you finally had a chance he
dies of old age… Talk about frustrating.
But despite everything his brother did,
Yoriichi still treasured a small flute that
his brother gave him when they were kids.
But now let’s back up and talk about Michikatsu -
Yoriichi’s brother - because he goes on to become
the Upper Moon One, Kokushibo. I just
explained about their shared childhood,
and how Michikatsu went from being the favored
child to the outcast, but once Yoriichi left,
Michikatsu eventually became the lord of his
family’s home. He married and had children,
but then one day a demon killed his soldiers
while they were out in the woods. Luckily,
Michikatsu was saved by Yoriichi, who was a demon
slayer at this point, and it was at this time
that Michikatsu decided to leave everything
behind and become a demon slayer as well.
He quickly learned his own breathing style -
Moon Breathing - and got his own demon slayer
mark. However, getting this mark was actually
the start of his downfall. Because every demon
slayer with the mark besides Yoriichi died before
their mid-twenties. So Michikatsu became obsessed
with survival and this eventually led him to
an encounter with Muzan. But because of his
intense desire to live, Michikatsu agreed to
become a demon and transformed into Kokushibo.
Then after years of killing humans, including the
leader of the Demon Slayer Corps, Kokushibo became
the upper moon one, and together with Muzan,
they wiped out every single demon slayer who
used the Sun Breathing style. But fast forward
sixty years, and Kokushibo only survived the
battle with Yoriichi because his brother died of
old age. This basically left him constantly angry
at his brother, even though he ended up taking his
brother’s treausred flute and keeping it himself.
But that’s actually not the end of his backstory,
because remember wife and kids he left
behind to become a demon slayer? Well,
that family actually were the past relatives of
the Mist Hashira, Muichiro Tokito. Which explains
exactly why Muichiro was so naturally talented
because he was related to Kokushibo and Yoriichi.
And while Muichiro eventually helped defeat
Kokushibo, he certainly wasn’t alone. Sanemi,
the Wind Hashira also took part in that
battle, and as we already explained with Genya,
he had the unfortunate task of killing his
mother who had transformed into a demon. But
that isn’t the end of his sad story because roamed
around killing demons on his own he was found by
a demon slayer named Masachika, who brought
Sanemi to a demon slayer trainer so he could
join the Corps. These two became basically like
brothers, but when they fought the lower rank one
demon, Masachika was killed in the battle. This
tragedy made Sanemi furious and he even snapped
at the leader of the demon slayer corps before
reading his dead friend’s will calmed him down.
Another of the participants in this legendary
battle is the strongest current demon slayer,
the Stone Hashira, Gyomei Himejima. And he also
has one of the wildest backstories. His mother
died giving birth to him and his father died of
some illness. To make things worse, a fever caused
him to go blind as a child. Eventually he was
living in a temple with a bunch of other orphaned
kids. Things went terribly wrong though when one
of the kids led a demon right to them. The demon
killed most of the other kids, even though Gyomei
tried to save them. The only one who survived
was the youngest girl who stayed behind Gyomei
while he punched the demon until the sun rose.
Unfortunately, this is not a happy ending.
Because that little girl got confused and
actually started babbling that Gyomei was a
monster. This made people believe that Gyomei
had killed the other kids and he was sentenced
to execution. Which is where he was headed until
he was saved by the leader of the demon slayer
corps, who brought him to become a demon slayer.
And all of that happened because of this slimy
kid right here. Kaigaku was living in the temple,
but was actually stealing their money. One night
he was caught by the other kids and forced out,
but then he ran into a demon. In order to save
his own life, he led the demon to the others,
which resulted in the tragic bloodbath. But that’s
not the end of his story because eventually he
was taken in by Jigoro, the former Thunder
Hashira, and trained alongside Zenitsu. However,
once he became a demon slayer, he ran
into Kokushibo and he chose to become a
demon instead of dying. Truly, he is one
of the worst people in the entire story.
Which makes it crazy that he became
a demon slayer in the first place,
because usually Kagaya Ubuyashiki is really good
at understanding people. I mean he basically
recruited all of the Hashira himself, and he
has earned all of their respect despite his
crippling illness. And if you didn’t know, that
illness runs through his family because of their
blood relation to Muzan. It’s basically a
curse that kills all the men before they
turn 30 and the women have to remarry and
change their name or they will die as well.
Even Kagaya’s father killed himself when he
was just 19 because he couldn’t handle seeing
so many demon slayers constantly dying. This
left Kagaya in charge at only the age of 4,
which is absolutely insane. Then when he was
thirteen, his wife, Amane, was selected to marry
him. Although he would only agree to marry her if
she actually wanted to. Which obviously she did
and she later gave birth to the Quintuplets:
Hinaki, Nichika, Kiriya, Kuina, Kanata.
But one thing Kagaya can’t do for himself is
fight, which is exactly the specialty of the Upper
Moon three, Akaza. As a kid his dad was very sick.
They didn’t have any money so Akaza would steal to
pay for his father’s medicine. However, he was
caught, and his father then committed suicide
because of shame. After this Akaza was banished
and he was eventually found by the leader of a
dojo. After living at the dojo for a few years,
Akaza became an incredibly strong fighter and
was even going to marry the leader’s daughter.
However, we can’t have a happy backstory so in
this case a jealous rival dojo leader poisoned
their drinking water. The dojo leader and his
daughter drank the poisoned water and died,
which sent Akaza into a rage and he literally
killed all sixty-seven members of the other dojo
with his bare hands. What an absolute monster.
And this display caught the attention of
Muzan, who then turned Akaza into a demon.
Which of course came during his battle against
Tanjiro and Giyu. Speaking of the Water Hashira,
he grew up with his older sister, but one day
she sacrificed herself to protect him from a
demon. After this, he was sent away to a distant
relative, but he ran away instead. This almost
turned out very bad though because he got lost
and nearly died on a mountain. He only survived
because he was rescued and trained by Urokodaki,
which sent him on a path to become a demon slayer.
Now we’ve already talked about the equally tragic
backstories of the Upper moon one and three,
but the Upper Moon 2, Doma’s childhood
was actually pretty easy in comparison.
He was born with extraordinary good looks
and for some reason people believed he
could communicate with the gods. So they
formed a cult with him as the leader,
even though Doma never believed any of
this. Then one day his mother killed
his father because he was cheating on him and
then she committed suicide. Doma didn’t really
care about any of this, and at twenty years
old he was turned into a demon by Muzan. He
still kept the cult going though, but now he
would eat the followers whenever he was hungry.
This leads us to some of the most important
backstories in all of Demon Slayer. Starting
with Obanai Iguro who has maybe the most tragic
backstory in the entire story. Basically,
he was born to a clan of thieves who
worshiped a snake demon. However,
this clan almost never had male
children sothe snake demon took
a very special interest in him. They even
kept him locked in a cage for most of his
childhood and snake demon would watch
him late at night. Yikes. Super creepy.
Years later when he was twelve he was let out of
the cage for the first time and he was immediately
brought to the snake demon. And this was very,
very bad for Obanai because the snake ordered
that his mouth be cut open kinda like the joker,
so that it matched the snake’s. After this Obanai
was desperate to escape, and his only happiness
came from this little snake who became his friend.
Eventually he managed to cut his way out of his
cage with a stolen hair pin, and he ran away. When
the snake demon found out she was furious and
killed nearly his entire family, before trying
to recapture Obanai. Fortunately, he was saved
by the former flame hashira, Shinjuro Rengoku,
which led Obanai to join the demon slayers because
of his deep hatred for the demon. Interestingly,
he also had a deep fear and hatred of women,
since his whole family that kept him locked up
were women. Although it is implied that
he actually fell in love with Mitsuri,
and it turns out that she loved him as well, so at
least he got some small joy before they both died.
Which brings us to another demon hater,
although this one is a demon herself. Tamayo,
who is the demon researching a cure to turn
Nezuko back into a human. But her story began
over 500 years ago. When she was 19 she fell ill
and was desperate for a cure. She then met Muzan,
who said he could cure her but he actually
just turned her into a demon instead. After her
transformation she mindlessly killed her husband
and children, which left her incredibly sad.
At some point she even tried to kill Muzan, but
she failed and this basically broke her spirit.
She gave up and basically ended up serving Muzan
until she broke free from his control after the
fight with Yoriichi. From this point on, she
stopped killing people and eventually was able
to live only by drinking blood, even though it
pained her not to eat people. Then over the next
200 years, she learned enough medical science
to modify her body to not need to eat humans.
Which of course brings us to the biggest demon
of them all, Muzan. And his backstory tells us
exactly how demons actually came to
exist. Over one thousand years ago,
Muzan was a sick human who nearly died in his
mother’s womb. He was going to be cremated because
his family thought he was dead but they only
took him out of the fire when he finally cried
out. Life did not get much better though because
his weak body kept getting worse. At some point
he started an experimental treatment from this
random doctor, but Muzan was so frustrated that
it wasn’t working that he eventually killed the
doctor. Only then did he realize that the medicine
was actually making him stronger, though in the
end it actually turned him into the first demon.
From this time he started eating humans
and growing stronger, with his main goal
to overcome his weakness to the sun. He tried
to do this in two ways. First by finding the
Blue Spider Lily flower which was part of the
medicine he took, which he was never able to
accomplish. The second way was to constantly
make demons so that one day a demon might have
the power to resist the sun. But maybe the
most unexpected thing about Muzan was that
during his early years as a demon, he actually
settled down with a woman five times. However,
each of these relationships ended with his
wife committing suicide because he was an
abusive husband. Which definitely makes him the
worst of the worst. Demon and deadbeat husband.
Over the centuries, he created the his Upper and
Lower moons by forcefully turning strong people
into demons. However, one strong fighter who
chose to die instead of becoming a demon was of
course the Flame Hashira, Kyoguro Rengoku. His
life ended after saving Tanjiro and the others
during the Mugen train arc. And while I already
told you about his mom dying, another fact from
his past is that during his first mission
as a demon slayer, he actually ruptured his
own eardrums to overcome a Flute Demon’s special
abilities. Yikes, talk about dedication to killing
demons. Which is of course why he chose to die
instead of becoming a monster himself. But I’ve
actually always wondered what might have happened
if he had actually chosen to live instead. Like,
would he become a GOOD demon or might he even have
the potential to become the strongest demon ever?
Well, you can learn the answer to all these
questions by watching this video right here.
Thanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.